the editor-in-chief of the athletic DC
he wrote a great piece that you should
all check out right now he's David
Aldridge back here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you da happy New Year to
you too I give you the floor on your
memories of David Stern first blush now
that he's passed on after the age of 77
David well you know it's kind of hard to
kind of encompass all of it and you know
a soundbite
he was a consequential person with
regard to a sport which is now the
second most popular sport on earth
behind soccer and he had a lot to do
with that both domestically and
internationally you know people have
asked me over the last 24 hours or so
something on some Birk variation of well
he had Michael Jordan at Malik's Magic
Johnson get Larry Bird and I I grant you
all of that that's exactly true
he was very fortunate that not only
those players but Charles Barkley and
Michael Jordan and Patrick Ewing and
Isiah Thomas and John Stockton and Karl
Malone all those players came into the
league basically at the same time he
created the platform upon which all of
those players became superstars he was
the guy that created opportunities for
people to see those players not only on
the court but also be able to see them
off the court to be able to watch them
on videos to be able to watch them
around the world with the rights fields
of the NBA made with all of the various
countries to see them in Olympic
competition on a enormous stage with the
dream team all of those things were
because David Stern one of those things
to happen or at least was able to make
them bigger I ask people you know
frequently if Mike Trout was walking
down Hollywood and Vine how much notice
would he get you know you know it
wouldn't get a lot of attention and
that's not a critique of
baseball but it just tells you that you
know it doesn't happen in every sport
with every superstar and it did in the
NBA under David Stern so how did he do
it because you know obviously the NFL
and and and its star players there's the
issue in many different ways
well facemask just in front you don't
see the face of the player in the same
way that obviously you would for for
Major League Baseball and there is
nothing out there except the player on
an NBA court and and the uniform he's
wearing what what did Stern actually do
well the important thing I think the
biggest thing was that he put the
attention on the court I mean you
remember when he got there there was
that infamous LA Times story that said
75% of the league was on drugs the games
were on tape delay so even if you were
NBA fan I remember watching Finals games
at 11:30 at night uh um you know if you
wanted to watch them because that was
the only way you got to watch them he
instituted the salary cap which allowed
teams critical all teams really to be
able to feel competitive teams because
the Lakers weren't spending four times
as much on salaries everybody else you
know the main thing was that he put the
emphasis on the game and on the floor
and what let people see his players see
those players you know do what they do
which is perform at incredibly high
levels so I think that was the first
thing you know in addition to that he
really pushed the league's corporate
sponsors to use players in
advertisements that was not normal but
he did that you didn't think black
players selling shoes or selling soft
drinks or selling hamburgers they did
that didn't happen you know he was able
to do that through his whatever force of
personality intimidation threat to go
somewhere else but it was a negotiator a
businessman as well as you know an
entertainment guy but NBA players
started being seen on commercials that
happened cousin David Stern
and that was a huge sea change in terms
of to your point people recognizing
these star players in this sport whereas
in other sports they did not they
weren't given those types of
opportunities as long as we're kind of
hitting the wayback machine as well
David I mean just a year after he became
commissioner was the famed 85 Draft
where Patrick Ewing
he pulled the envelope out of the
ping-pong ball I guess taurine if you
will and and out of the envelope logo
was the NYX logo right you know there's
still so much oliver stoning about that
do you think there was any any there's
any smoke to that fire about what
happened in that 85 draft with you and
going to the nation well as i have often
said rich if the NBA is in the business
of conspiracies it really sucks at it
okay if it was all about making New York
good how's that working out you know
what I mean
you know it was all about making Chicago
good how's that worked out since Jordan
left you know I mean so it's it's it's
ridiculous and you know it's easy to say
because you don't require any proof and
if someone says this is ridiculous and
here's why that's just more evidence of
a conspiracy among people who believe in
those sorts of things so there's nothing
you can do to keep people from from
doing that every year before the draft
if the Knicks or the Lakers are involved
they're going to get the first pick we
all know it's rigged and then when they
don't get the first pick like neither of
them got last year and they didn't get
the second pick either people say well
they're just doing this to make New
Orleans good because New Orleans lost
Anthony Davis yeah because the real
emphasis of the NBA is to make sure the
New Orleans market continues to thrive
you know I mean come on so you can truck
in those things if you want I don't
believe in dumb that I would never say
never about anything right you know the
ability to pull that off require the
same amount of ability it would take to
cover up the Kennedy assassination for
the last 50 years which a lot of people
still believe right David Aldridge here
on the Rich Eisen show to me I'd say
well you know one of the most important
if not the most important things that
David Stern did
or his handling of a situation when he
was Commissioner was Magic Johnson
having to leave the game because of
being hiv-positive and then returning to
the game I've got Charles Barkley on in
our number three and I'm wondering what
you can bring to light about David
Stern's handling of that matter and its
importance David oh well there's no
there's no question I really do believe
for instead you know the NBA's response
to Magic Johnson being HIV positive was
one of the first it wasn't the certainly
first but it was one of the first real
turning points in terms of public
awareness and understanding about HIV
and AIDS because look we all thought we
all thought the same thing we conflated
HIV with AIDS so if you had HIV you had
agent if you had AIDS you're gonna die
that's what we all thought back in the
80s you know and so the league was able
in it and it wasn't just that was not
just crackpot theory there were NBA
all-stars who believed the same thing
you know believed that has if Magic
sweated on them they could get HIV and
so the league had to be very out front
on that and and in saying that he was
going to play not just in the not just
in the all-star game but in the on the
dream tape you know I mean that was you
can't fathom how big the dream team was
in 1992 and the fact that he was allowed
to play encouraged to play on that team
was just a huge
I think turning point in people's
understanding and maybe empathy towards
others who had HIV and AIDS and and
again Stern was righted incentive rose
of the league's kind of evolution on
that because it was not it was not a
linear decision it took them some time
to reach that decision it took them a
few weeks to come to reach that decision
but after consulting with the top
medical people at the time they did
reach that decision and it was it true
that he basically told some of the
players in a meeting that he was in that
that if if they didn't agree to let
magic back in or at least be on board
with the disease
that he would HIV test the entire league
because if they wouldn't allow magic
back in he had to find out who who also
needs to be out there's there there's
probably some truth there I don't know
if it was specifically in a meeting
right if this was conveyed to players
you know individually as they and their
agents called the league but that was
certainly conveyed to those players like
that that you know we if you wanted me
to test magic then we're going to test
everybody and you know I don't think
anybody wanted only anybody wanted that
smoke race so right now that that was a
quick decision you know and again he the
way he played in the all-star game and
incredible performance he put on that
day really I think started to kind of
ease people's uncertainty and and
discomfort what's playing on the floor
with him and against him last one for
you David you got a good personal story
of dealing with David Stern where you
might have been on the wrong business
end or of anything or a story that
leaves to mind about David's style
I got cussed out oh I got cussed out
many times by David many times how so
long Oh almost always almost always
involving the lockout you know I was I'm
old enough that I covered three of them
it was not fun those are not fun right
those are not fun times at all and
because of the difference between the
Union which is comprised of four hundred
players each of what each of whom has an
opinion about this and has you know
dozens of lawyers that are also willing
to talk to you about it the NBA had one
person speaking for it and that was
David Stern because he threatened
everybody else was six or seven figure
fines if they talked including owners I
mean he fined Michael Jordan he fined
Micky Arison during lockouts
he fined Ted Leonsis during lockouts for
seemingly innocuous things they said
during those lockouts about one issue
the other so he wasn't playing around so
you didn't get you just didn't have
access to a lot of league people and
what happened is that when you're
covering it you would talk to union
people who would tell you this is what
we want this is where the league is
being unreasonable and so you would put
that out there and David didn't like
that because he made it seem like you
know you were and you were back in the
Union in this so you let you know about
it
vociferously profanely and it happened
multiple times over the years while I
was covering the league you know and it
was just so different you know you're
getting screaming mentions people all
the time you know people don't like what
you wrote or what said or what you did
you know and those things all happen and
it's part of doing the job rich I'm sure
you've had issues over the years with
people you don't ever you don't take it
personally you don't remember them
you're I remember when David Stern
cursed me out it wasn't David Stern
cursed you out because he made you feel
like about two inches tall but again if
you had your if you had your information
correct you would be willing to listen
to what you had to say that's the most
important thing having your information
correct love love the call David thank
you happy new to you and you and yours
and let's check in about actual sports
as opposed to life and things like this
we'll chat down the road rich my best to
you and your family as well Happy New
Year thanks for Apple right back at you
at David Aldridge DC for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app